it's going to be very interesting to see
ultimately what surfaces and and what
survives you know that that's the
ultimate test of whether the technology
can be feasible at scale because
otherwise if we uh you know just pour
money into any Grand idea but it's not
scalable and it's not measurable then it
just won't do any good because it'll be
like trying to uh you know empty the
ocean with a spoon
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
welcome to 20 minute leaders today I'm
with Ruth Dagan partner and head of the
environment and climate change practice
at hilzogi Law Firm she recently has
been appointed as an advisor to the
United Nations climate change convention
Secretariat on carbon markets and has
been leading environmental and climate
law practitioner in Tel Aviv and New
York for over two decades she holds a
doctorate from nyu's school of law
specializing in environmental Finance
her practice is deeply focused on
climate-related technological innovation
development of carbon offsetting
projects and carbon Market transactions
she works closely with the multitude of
international corporations tech
companies financial institutions and
investors to develop curated carbon
strategies tailored to their unique
needs and targets she's a firm believer
in markets and is involved in both
National and international forums
developing carbon Market tools and
policies
really appreciate you taking the time I
know how busy you are the work that
you're doing and is it taken very
seriously now and as the world is
gearing up very seriously and obviously
cup 27 just happened recently and we
have a quite a bit of you know energy
surrounding energy and and carbon
emissions and and the whole industry is
you know really putting its uh it's it's
not only the you know our energy and our
thoughts but also our resources into
trying to understand what are the really
the best ways for us to to tackle a lot
of these emerging issues and so I'm
really happy to have you here and talk a
little bit about your own you know your
own passion for for the ecosystem that
we're in your own your own position
within the ecosystem and a little bit
about your story so again thank you for
being here tell me a little bit about
you know what you really care about what
does it that you really care about wow
okay
so actually
um I I think that um the the path that
I've taken I probably it's taken
several decades to get to this point but
uh uh probably somehow in the back of my
mind I knew from inception that this is
what was meant to be and I somehow
inexplicably was uh very attracted to uh
this content matter and uh anything
related to uh environment and
environmental science and climate
science ultimately and since
unfortunately I I thought I don't have
the appropriate skills to be a scientist
and I chose to be a lawyer
then I I decided to connect these two
Fields together and do what I can in the
field law and policy and regulation to
put forward the important causes within
environment and climate change so that's
ultimately what actually led me to where
I am today
all right that that's that's really cool
and so
how does that day look like you know
what you do in the day today what is
that actually taking place with
okay wow well so
um I actually have uh you know a very
very Diversified
workload and the typical day would
probably include working on various
transactions it can be M A transactions
or investment uh deals within companies
that are in the environment and climate
Tech space
okay so that's something that really uh
taking off lately and a lot of uh VC
funds and and uh just uh major
International corporations are looking
into investing in Innovative
Technologies Into Climate Tech space
this is a very broad uh ecosystem and
many many uh technology companies can
actually
connect to the climate narrative and and
provide various Solutions uh whether
they've been actual reduction or
elimination of greenhouse gas emissions
or any type of technology that would be
able to Monitor and verify reductions
and uh
solutions to these emissions and any
type of Technologies there actually even
collect connected to blockchain
that can look at the chain of
reductions and and how they are
transferred from Corporation to
Corporation and the keep track of those
reductions so this is a a very
Diversified field today that everybody
is looking into and that's something
that we actually work on with our
clients both a woman
representing the tech companies
themselves and investors so that's one
uh aspect of what I do in a day I also
work a lot on regulatory aspects
um so so we work a lot with corporations
and financial institutions that are
looking at uh Trends major Trends within
the climate space today they're
literally it's like a moving Target that
every single day sometimes several times
a day you see some sort of
regulatory initiative coming out many
times it's out of the European Union and
it actually affects the entire Globe
it's like a ripple effect that comes out
of Europe and they're saying okay we
expect these and these types of
standards that the corporations need to
adhere to and this is what expected this
is what is expected did from now on and
these regulatory Trends really affect
how corporations behave and what type of
tech Investments they would look to in
order to find solutions to their pain
their climate pain
so that's another aspect and for me like
I I guess the uh uh ultimate uh cherry
on top would be uh the work that I do
within the carbon markets that's working
a lot on deals that their Essence is to
commercialize the commodity that is the
reduction of greenhouse gas emissions
and uh work on projects that allow for
offsetting and and essentially what
happens there in carbon magnets is that
um
this is basically a liver a tool to
finance uh projects that allow
decarbonization of the economy and
um these deals that are just
accelerating and happening basically all
over the world now are soon expected to
become a part of an international
emissions trading system that would be
supervised by the European Union
so this is another major thing that we
actually do my team and myself on a
daily basis and it's really fascinating
now balancing a no obviously you know
the the two backgrounds sounds really
really cool I'm curious as we're you
know understanding that this is a
concern not um not just you know
economically you know financially this
is a worldwide you know
challenge that we're all that we all
need to tackle what is the role of
organizations that are not climate right
you have you know so many companies most
companies are not labeling themselves as
climate texts and I'm curious as to how
how do these organizations
sure how should they in your opinion
react to everything that's happening now
do they need to react is there something
that they can react with
yes absolutely so um
they have a role they have a significant
role to play in this transition economy
that essentially is going to be moving
from the situation that we're in right
now which is a carbon intense economy to
a net zero carbon economy and that is
something that's going to be happening
over the course of the next uh one to
two decades it's a very slow process but
we're there already we're within this
transition period and all corporations
or all human activity has a role to play
Within this transition so definitely uh
companies that don't see themselves as
being the solution need to find a way to
adopt uh and internalize these external
Solutions into their own processes and
activities and that's their role of
Inception
got it okay and so
are things changing industry-wide to
allow for new incentives to come into
place for these companies or for these
leaders what what do CEOs of companies
do you know in relation to these
emerging changes that we have
yeah
oh they heard about variety of both
courses of action that they can adopt in
this context and uh first of all
obviously you cannot ignore a regulation
okay so there are very clear regulatory
signals that are being sent to the
economy and to the uh corporations in
all sectors across economy uh generally
just stating a very clear message listen
uh
um carbon emissions are no longer
legitimate everyone needs to act to
reduce them and to eliminate them
ultimately so the regulatory
um signals they're being sent in a very
I would say sophisticated way because
the the main actors who are now
um under this regulation are actually
the financial ones okay so so basically
what the regulator is saying I am going
to press hard
where the money is and once the
financial actors are under this
regulation and they are required to
address their climate risk the risk that
is inherently uh internal to the funds
that they provide the loans that they
provide the Investments that they make
um once we do that that will ultimately
spill over into the real corporations
that have actual operations on the brand
which ultimately cause the emissions so
that's the major and heaviest regulatory
Trend the financial one and then of
course we're seeing gradually more and
more of Regulation that is direct to
reduce emissions in addition to that
there is an entire universe of uh
economic incentives
really being thrown at corporations that
uh need to somehow
finance and do a lot of r d work in
order to develop processes that are less
carbon intense so they're uh sort of uh
these two worlds that need to work
together both the regulation and the
incentives
yeah let's talk a little bit about the
the incentives right you know it almost
sounds like there's the sort of there's
the you know why you should if you do
this you'll win or if you do this you'll
you know you yeah you want to avoid
losing right sort of uh
um an interesting balance I'm I'm PR I'm
curious I'm always curious about the you
know both pieces but I'm particularly
curious about healthy economic
incentives that guide you know
individuals to make decisions that are
in their favor you know it's a win-win
tell me a little bit about how we what
we've learned in your eyes about the
successful economic incentives of doing
something that is not trivial as an
industry
okay so I I hope I don't disappoint you
but uh I actually I I have a pretty
realistic if not to say cynical view of
economic incentives coming from the
government because it at least uh my my
experience here on the ground uh they're
probably not enough said
the the
challenge of the young behavior and
economic decisions and choices is so
deep and and uh so significant that
these economic incentives alone will not
be enough it's like a dropping the ocean
however they can be a catalyst they can
help because once the government signals
that it is behind a certain course of
action or technology or a certain
project that addresses greenhouse gas
emissions that signal alone is
completely worth it and and will allow
for additional Investments uh to flow in
that specific Direction so sometimes
even if they don't if the state doesn't
actually write the check uh you know
with a certain
funding flowing into a specific project
the mere fact that they say okay we're
behind this this sounds good to us and
we'll work with it and will not try to
somehow circumvent the project with uh
you know piling out of bureaucracy and
the regulatory requirements on it
that ultimately delay these projects and
make them just uh impractical to
implement
then that in itself will really go a
long way into moving us forward of
course uh you know actual funds for for
such project can always help but they
are not the game changer it's a game
changer is the signal that the state
will send and that will ultimately allow
for uh funds and and uh private uh
funding actors to come in and and give
them necessary backing Finance wise
very cool where where are we headed in
your eyes where are we now at the right
at the beginning of 2023 a lot of I mean
everything is crazy it sounds like
there's so many different things
happening you know I'm in the generative
AI space and so I've it's kind of crazy
me how many different
Industries we have now we're different
verticals that are just exploding that
we're left just thinking you know what
is happening and what can we get excited
about so what where you know what's
exciting from your lens for this
upcoming year or months decade
yeah absolutely so
um I I can definitely say that where
we're going with this uh the the
ultimate climate challenge is the fact
that uh first of all there are still
many technologies that are really
um not ripe enough for our actual
implementation uh they're very
experiment
experimental they're very risky and
um
it's going to be very interesting to see
ultimately what surfaces and and what
survives you know that that's the
ultimate test of whether the technology
can be feasible at scale because
otherwise if we uh you know just pour
money into any Grand idea but it's not
scalable and it's not measurable then it
just won't do any good because it'll be
like trying to uh you know empty the
ocean with a spoon
you can keep on going but it's not going
to take us anywhere the magnitude of the
changes that that's required is so
enormous that you need technologies that
are scalable that's the key one second
thing is that
um the reductions that are measured need
to be reliable and need to be monitored
accurately so that there is trust in the
market otherwise there will not be
funding of these Technologies and
projects because no one is going to be
able to tell reliably if they do produce
the results that they claim they claim
they can produce so anything related to
mrv the worlds of monitoring reporting
and verification of greenhouse gas
reductions those are the worlds of
technology of tomorrow and and
definitely that's where everybody is
going to be looking to and of course the
uh
probably the expansion of carbon markets
and creation of a lot of standards in
order to create uh reliable activity
within carbon markets which is the
ultimate financing tool for uh
decarbonization so though those are
probably the main trends that I would
look to in the coming few years
amazing and how do you see your your
role a change evolve as as these things
evolve you know over the over these
years
yeah so um I think that probably one of
the main things that I've been fortunate
enough to be able to do uh over the
course of the past several months is
being involved as a consultant to uh the
United Nations to the team that is
actually working on uh the rules and
modalities of the international
emissions trading system that is slated
to become operational within several
years
so that's been fascinating work and I'm
really honored that I have this
opportunity and
um I'm really hoping that you know this
project will come into fruition quickly
it's going to make a global change and
the mere fact that I can be a part of
that is is really thrilling for me
um so so that's something major that's
going to be developing and uh also I
think that probably
since I'm really at the center of what's
Happening uh within carbon markets in
general and and climate policy and
because it really uh
it touches the pawn every aspect of the
economy it's going to be fascinating to
see how governments deal with it how
actors within the market deal with it
how the financial sector deals with it
and it really touches upon every single
aspect of the economy and we're really
seeing an evolutionary process that
fascinating in every possible way I
would say
thank you so much best of luck with all
the amazing work that you do I really
appreciate your time and your your
energy and uh continue will continue
cheering from the side thank you very
much
thank you Michael it was a pleasure
talking to you
[Music]